[Musique]
j'ai commencé dans les écoles comme face
à enseigner les arts par le papier je
n'ai pas pu cette technique de plus de
plus en plus et aujourd'hui c'est ma
passion dans la fortune sculptures de
papier le papier pour moi c'est un
matériau qui est près de la terre comme
s'en aller mais que c'est pas une
matériaux artificiels si le matériau
qu'on peut vous palpitant putsch et
qu'on peut travailler quand publié il ya
il est temps des dinosaures tu nous en a
déjà parlé
je démens 10 me tiennent mieux joveneau
mon métier
jésus et ses apôtres ont préparé le
repas traditionnel qui au jour les
cérémonies de la grande fête de pâques
le 44e les venger leurs épisodes jeunes
ça marqué ma carrière
sa marque est un peu litigieux n'est pas
comme si c'était vous plonger de
l'église à cause de souffrance et que
les 4,7 et à ses proches un peu par
quatre d'un coup
non je suis pour y asseoir les apôtres
sont au bord du lac de tibériade le team
le premier tony parce qu'il est possible
pour ce dimanche matin à 9h45 fois une
haute école soit quand je rencontre des
gens même encore maintenant
merci la voix bercé mon enfance et ça
pour moi j'aime mieux ça que les
félicitations nouveau capture is weak
stress de mahler jeunes et recycler les
écorces phoenix à 13 sa pour les venger
leur papier ça c'est que ça tu as vu le
film et ça c'est une école en pâtit ça
peut être ça se faisait au cinéma il
polit tattoo jouer avec les bêtes des
rapports privilégiés
j'ai fait aussi qu'elle se décore le
théâtre la télévision
salez combler sa villa fond noir ça
c'est moi qu'avec les c'était
l'invention que cette émission ne me
ferme et et ça je le maintiens pascal en
liberté je travaillais les missionnaires
les boudins je travaille à l'émission
assouly verte et le québec peut
maintenant s'enorgueillir de son système
de foi et communication quand je le fais
le défilé de la saint jean a fait 24
heures tout un papier mais tout avait
été réalisée en aluminium
j'ai fait d'autres choses et qu'on les
appelle les rois mages les faits les
soirs une scène est aussi une réponse
très positive
j'adorerais ça travaille sur la scène
j'enseignais cher bloc commence à se
connaître montréal
les ateliers travers le québec j'ai
enseigné university montréal indique m
alors ça vous montre tout des
expériences fort intéressant
[Musique]
quand génial un jeune avec des
ordinateurs et un body ce n'est pas les
choses mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut faire un beau mais touché avec mon
gré fabriquer toucher la matière ce
n'est pas juste
volvo résultats le visiteur est reportée
six fois vous exprimer
elle est vraiment fait ma vie et ses
matériaux etc mais qui me souviens pas
mais j'en suis très heureux parce que je
suis moins éternel moi c'est fini mais
cache message
ça m'a fait beaucoup de joie de bonheur
alors pour moi c'est ça qui est proclamé
[Musique]